Hello, I'm Kabu.
Thank you very much. Please. Please.
[Music] Masue
Kabu. I'm Maguro Taniguchi, vocalist and guitarist. Hello. Hello, I'm Koizumi, drummer. Yes, I'm
Koha, guitar player. Beth.  Good morning Hello Good evening Yes, I
have a question.
Yes, please tell me how it was formed. I
see. I'm 16 years old, a first year high school
student.  That's when
we met.I wanted to start a band, and
Unkoi-chan was sitting next to me.Yes, it was
nice to meet you.I entered the school
from the first day.I didn't even bring a pen, so I
lent it to Unkoi-chan.  Well, we
went to college together, so these two are childhood
friends and have been together since elementary school.So,
that kid was
invited to join the band, or rather, he was invited to music studies.
Well, I
guess I'll go too. Well, the first band we formed was Cub.
Yeah, that's
better. We went to high school in different schools at the time, but we became good friends.
Since then, we've been together with Maguro.  We've been
friends for a really
long time, living together, but we joined
last year, last year, last year, April of 2022, and
now we've been together for a long time.  As
for Naruto, a
lot of overseas fans got to know about Kabu through Naruto, but they're probably
watching this. I'm sure
you like Naruto, too.He's the
representative of Japan.  Since it's an anime, please tell me the
highlight of when you provided a song for Naruto. Is that a memory? Well, at
first I was in charge of a song called Silhouette for the TV
anime Naruto.
Yeah, I was happy. Yeah, I was happy.
After all, Ode Mercy is still in that period.I
started watching the Naruto manga when I was in elementary school, and I
watched it in real time when it was really popular, so I was
really involved in Naruto
from the time it debuted.  Yeah, yeah, that dream came
true, and we all
watched it on Sony Music, at this company, and I
couldn't help but cry, but that kind of
emotion is something you don't get to experience very often, so I
was really happy.  Well,
Marcy was watching it too, right? Well, that's how it turned out, and that's
when it hit the big time, so it was on
TV everywhere. While
I was working there, I was also working part-time on TV.
While working part-time, we got really excited at the live performance, and once again we felt how amazing this song was
and how important it was to us.It's very
Sylhet after all.Everyone was
singing it in Japanese.That's why
this song is still so great.
It was the same when it came out, but even now, I'm being
given a really fresh impression. Yes, I have
a lot of happy questions.
Yes, it's a
Naruto game.
Ultimate Storm 4, Spiral,
Spiral.  Yeah, it's really
the best.The silhouette is the best.But, yeah, I
'm asking you to tell me about the process you go through when creating songs related to Naruto.
We have a special connection to Naruto,
and since it's a manga, manga, and
anime that we've watched in real time, we
don't really feel any pressure.  Or rather, when we
naturally think about what Naruto or
Boruto or something like that means to us, a
song naturally comes to us, and
when we do a tie-up with someone else,
or about another theme, we come up with a song.  I keep in
mind the original work when I create it, but
so far I've been working on about 5 or 5 episodes together, and they've
been able to do it very naturally,
so I guess I can't say it's strange.
When I do the Naruto series, I
often focus on the scenery, the techniques, and the like, and find something that draws me in, like the stars or the
spirals.  We create phrases that are conscious of the sound, and things like
that.Yeah, yeah, the
only thing in this band is the Rasengan, and I've
heard that all the members are big fans of Naruto, so
of course we do live performances.
When I perform, for example, when I play a Naruto song,
what kind of feeling do I have?
As a fan, I think about something, or something like what
I was talking about earlier, so I
make a song about that.  Sometimes,
when I'm creating a phrase, I imagine the scenery or technique from Naruto.There
are many times when I'm imagining it and drawing it out, so the
opening actually plays in my head.
But when I saw the excitement around Canada, Indonesia,
and Saudi Arabia, I
couldn't think about that anymore.I just wanted to connect with the person in front of me.
Yeah, yeah,
when I gave a lecture overseas, the
first thing that came to my mind was the original author,
Mr. Kishimoto.
Ah, the existence of Mr. Kishimoto. Until now, I had
met and had a conversation with Mr. Kishimoto, the original author of Naruto.
Well, I
made a song called Diver, and
when I performed it at an event, Mr. Unki burst into tears and was so
happy that I was
so happy.  I remember
that, so when I'm doing silhouettes overseas, I
think about Mr. Kimoto, thank you for bringing me, and I
think about showing it to Mr. Kishimoto.Yes, I
think about things like that.
In addition to Naruto, I have also worked on various anime songs
such as My Hero Academia, Endless Fire Brigade, and
recently Ezon 100,
but
when I first started the band, I
was involved in so many great works.  Have you ever imagined a band? I've always
thought that I wanted to be in a good band, a cool band.  I've been
imagining it, but I never
imagined that I would be able to collaborate with anime and anime in such a deep and diverse way.Even
when I did Naruto with Naruto and Silhouette, I never imagined that I would be able to be
involved with anime one after another like this.  I've
always wanted to work with Naruto,
so I could imagine that,
but I can't
imagine being able to work with all the other anime characters.
Yes, it's
strange. Kanaboon and the
anime must be compatible. Yes, the
mirror ball guy appears. My
Hero Academia's theme star marker. Yes, yes, the mirror ball. Mira ball, the man.  The
person who gave it to me
said that he loved it. That was funny.
After all, he was a professional dancer. He
danced in front of us with such sparkling sparkles.
But that was funny.  Naunma:
How are you involved in the creative process of the music video?
But basically, the director who is in charge of us, the
director's ups and downs at the time, etc.
Through communication between the director and the director, we
came up with a plan, so we've
been through a lot of difficult filming,
but if we're asked to do something, we'll do whatever we want.  Is
there such a thing? If you were to
direct someone, who would it
be among these four? Makoi-chan has done parodies once,
so
what kind of video would you like to make?  Well, I made it once, and it was me who
made it myself, and it
seemed like everyone was changing to me, so on the
other hand, I
wanted to think about how to move things around and make it.
If we do that, then no, no, there won't be any
performances, so we'll have
everyone act, so we'll have to make it in a drama style.What role will each role have? Well, it depends
on the concept, but the most
interesting thing is to make it stand out.  That's because Koga
often plays the main role, and
Koga plays the role of the girl, the girl, the
girl, the father, etc., and I watched her, and I
looked at her, oh yeah, that's right, sky
diving.  I'd like to do something
like that. Please let me
know about your upcoming project album tour.
Well, in Japan, we'll be touring all over Japan starting in the fall. Well, there are
47 locations, but we'll be
touring all of them.  I did it once five years ago
, but this year is the 10th
anniversary of my debut, so I'm going to do it.Yes, yes, the
first release of Mazon 100, Nguoza
Det, has been released, so I think I'd like to make an album as well.  I'm
always thinking about it.It's
tough because as soon as I say "I want to
make something," it gets made, so it's tough, but I always
feel like I want to make something, and somehow I always have the energy, so I
want to go overseas.Actually,
this year.  I heard that they had various invitations towards the end of the show,
like in the fall, or in South America,
but they had a domestic tour of their own, so they
couldn't go because of their schedules.  But I want to go again next year. I want to
go to places I've never been before, Saudi Arabia,
Indonesia, Canada. I
want to say yes, and I want to
go to places I've never been before, so please invite someone.
Please, please
[Music]
Let's ask all sorts of questions, one question at a time.
Yeah, I
feel like I learned a lot from that cool opening.The main story is also
great.My favorite anime is Naruto,
but I like an anime called Otaxi.I really
like the reasoning behind it, so I'm an
otaku.  It's a great work.My favorite anime is a
blues anime.I
guess it's a manga.I like youth, so it's a
street fight manga where young men talk in elementary school.  Chan:
Because I like it, that's how I am. Hey,
Ojimajo Doremi.
Ah, I wonder if people overseas know this Ojimajo. There's a
song called "Ojimajo Carnival," which is the theme song for Doremi.
Dream Yeah, there's no song like this that's that catchy and
great. Who's
the artist at the top of the playlist I'm listening to right now
? The most recent one is Ore Hive. Ah, I recently
bought a new album, so I've been listening to it and it's amazing. It's cool, yeah,
pretty good.  I've always liked it,
yes, I've liked it for a long time, but it came out recently, so
what do you think? I'm a
young Japanese guy, and I lie to you. I've been listening to it for a long time. Yeah, it's
cool. Kofumi:
Teacher Ghibli music. Yeah, I've been listening to Ghibli a lot
lately.  I thought that the way it was made was amazing, and I
heard the orchestral version of it, and I
thought it was so greedy.Yeah, I didn't really have that image in my head.Oh yeah, it was really
good, fantastic, and I listened to a
lot of amazing Canadian bands.  Well, as of
now in 2023, I was
listening to that playlist the most. I
just looked up who the artist was, and found out that they
were Foo Fighters. I guess it's like that every year,
but I'm also listening to Foo Fi
because they release a new album.
If you could be a Naruto character, which character would
you be? Oh, I'm super. I'm definitely super. It's almost a
long life. Yeah, I want to live a long life, and now I'm like this. Lose weight, lose weight, lose weight, lose weight.  Of course I
want to become a character, but I like Momo,
and I've been doing it for a while, so if I can
get that kind of agility, then I'm
actually going to do karate, which I used to do, but I'm
worried.  I wonder if it's Shimaru, I have a crush on that intelligent type.
Yeah, I'm sure I
want to know how and what he's thinking. Oh yeah, he's got insight, and he's a staff
officer. He's a character. He's
cool, then who are we?
Let's become the ramen master of the easy way.I'm
probably from Naruto.I've
been repeating myself, so
what's the song I often sing at karaoke?I guess it's
Ulfurus.I
sing Ulfurus.  This is Sasuke's
Blue Venge, Ah, Sasuke, a little Naruto,
Sasuke,
and Sasuke-san's Blue Venge, and I'm
playing a lot of songs. Yeah, yeah, this is it. I've
heard HY's letter so many times. I'm a
high school girl.  I sing it all the time. I
love you. I'm an Asian. I'm an Asian. I can
sing any song.
Yeah, I'm an Uzumaki fan. I'm a Uchiha fan. Yeah, I'm a Uzumaki
fan. I can't choose. I can't choose this one. If it actually belongs to me, then it
belongs to me.  When it comes to actually going crazy,
Matty doesn't really
think that deep, that's not it, it's
just a general idea that he thinks about it deeply.It's just that I like that story, or
maybe it's
me or my family.  That's cool
Yeah, Riga Sharinga is me,
definitely a whirlpool, a whirlpool, yeah, I'm a whirlpool, yeah, I'm a whirlpool too, yeah, I'm a whirlpool too, yeah, I'm a fan of the way I
dress, yeah, I'm a fan of my
hairstyle, too,
but I still want to live in peace.
This is a difficult question.It's difficult to
describe Kanabun in one word.I want
someone to say the opposite:
Turnip is one word, money is one word.I'm
about to say it already.
Not at all, but I still feel the love from those fans, and
now we're
expressing our love for so many different things.I
feel so much love for everything, including to the audience.  Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
I'm still friends, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm
just a friend, but we started out as just friends, so that's why
that relationship continues even now.
Yeah, yeah, it's like
friendship or friends, but some of my friends are better than me, and I
have some friends who have a mutual understanding of me,
and the relationship with the audience is pretty
close.It doesn't feel like artists and customers.
I think it's probably true that we're more like
friends than we are, so in that sense, I think it's probably true that we're talking about friendship to such an extent.
Yeah, it
's definitely Friends.
Even in Unki Friends, Koi-chan
said something like that.  Sense of
Distance I want to be as close as possible to my fans.That's right.We belong to
rock stars.We
don't want to be different, or something like that.I don't have any intention of
becoming a revered figure,
but I do it properly.  Those who
listen, those who watch, those who watch, I'm
always there for the fans.I want to be a
rock hero.My memories are, I want to be.Yes, yes, yes.What is
this?Candy Candy.It's a
stick.It's a stick.  Now, I'm going to
ask you a lot of questions, so I
'm going to ask you to name someone who
fits that category.  Sechocho Let me
think about the members who can be different, let's say
yes, they're all separate, all of them are
separate.
Yeah, I'm pretty good at tidying up a
country that I
probably can't govern with the other members, and I think I can pass through the country if I do my own thing.  I'm not sure if it's
possible or not, putting aside popularity and
other things, and
whether or not I can do office work.If I were to ask if I could do office work, I'd probably be
able to eat more ramen than Naruto.Which
member is that?  Well, whoever it is, whoever it is, it looks
like it's going to get beat up because it's just a good body.
I say I can't make a substitute, but seriously, the
body made from ramen is scary, but in reality, it's better if you don't
eat a lot.  It's better not to
eat in front of other people when you can see
how much you're eating, but it's better to hide and eat in front
of other people.Although it's true that the image of the appearance is that it's the best to eat.I
understand, but find new music.  I wonder
who the members are.
I'm sure there's a tuna fish. I'm
sure it's good. I'll
listen to it and recommend it. I
think it's pretty good from Mercy.  Either way, I'll say it all from me to myself.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, that's
right, that's the pop punk playlist you sent me, the other day, all the time, on the plane in Canada.
When the world is full of zombies, I'll be the last
member to survive.  Let's
break up. I'm here. I'm here.
Yeah, I think I'll be the first to get hit. No, it's much better. I'm going to shut myself in. Oh, I'm going to
pay for it, so I'll
prepare some things in advance.  In advance, in advance,
I understand that Zombie Panic is understandable,
I know that Amoneki is absolutely
different, and watching zombie movies is different too.
2 has HOW 2, so I'm going to select
members who seem to be able to control the Gundam well.
Yes, I'm going to get into the Gundam and
find members who are likely to be able to control the Gundam well. Yes, it's a
battle between battles. No, I'm a
Gundam fan, so I'm also this and that.  Well, which
one of us can do that with just the two of us?I mean,
which one is better at simply driving?I'm good at
cleaning machines that I've never driven before, so I
have a forklift license.I also
have a license for a regular car.  That's the nickname I have.
Ruko has a special license, so
yes, Kanab
will do a world tour someday.Yes, I want to do it, yes, I want to do it.For
that reason, I'm going to many places now, so I think he
knows us.  If
you're listening, I'll definitely see you again. Please wait. Thank you.
[Music]
HV